So there are two correct answers, the third one, and
the fifth one. And this is why a hash table is such a great
advance over the linear index, is that we can double the number of keywords, and
double the number of buckets, and the look up
time stays the same. With the linear index, if we
double the number of keywords for each look up, we
need to go through the loop once for each keyword.
If the keyword was near the end or one that wasn't
in the table, the time to look up the keyword would
double as we double the number of keywords. With a hash
table if we also double the number of buckets when we double
the number of keywords, well then the number of keywords in
each bucket stays the same. We're dividing the keywords evenly between
buckets. So this is the number, the number of keywords per
bucket is the number of keywords divided by the number of buckets.
If we double both, that number stays approximately the same. The
time to look up only depends on the number of keywords per
bucket. The time to find the bucket is very fast, right? We
just need to run the hash function, find that element of the
list. Both of those don't depend on the size of the
list, how long it takes to do that. And then we have
to look through the bucket, the size of the bucket, we have
to look though each element in the bucket one at a time.
So if we keep the number of key words per bucket
the same, the look up time stays essentially the same. So that's
the great property that hash tables have. If we double the
number of buckets, as we double the number of keywords, the expected
look up time doesn't change. For the other possibilities, well if
we double the number of keywords and keep the same number of
buckets, that's going to get slower because the number of keywords
per bucket will approximately double. So it's going to take about twice
as long for each look up. If we keep the same
number of keywords, but double the number of buckets, well then it's
going to actually get faster. We'll have the same number of keywords, double
the number of buckets. So, this value will be approximately half of
what it was before. The expected lookup time will be about
half of what is before we doubled the number of buckets. If
we halve the number of keywords keeping the same number of buckets,
well that has essentially the same affect. The average number of keywords
per bucket will be half of what it
was before, so the expected lookup time will be
about half of what it was. And finally
if we have both, well that's going to keep
the ratio the same so the expected look
up time will be about the same. So that's
why these two are the correct answers, that those
are expected to leave the lookup time essentially unchanged.